[MUSIC PLAYING]
MEGHAN MEHTA: We have
had so much fun showing
you I/O. But now it's
time to hear from I/O.
Let's go do some meetup.
How many festivals have
you been to so far?
SPEAKER 1: How many?
MEGHAN MEHTA: Google I/O.
SPEAKER 1: This is my second.
MEGHAN MEHTA: It's
your second Google I/O?
SPEAKER 2: This is my first one.
SPEAKER 3: This is my fourth.
MEGHAN MEHTA: It's
your fourth one?
SPEAKER 4: My fourth as well.
MEGHAN MEHTA: Wow.
What about you guys?
SPEAKER 5: You're
at the fourth I/O?
SPEAKER 4: Yeah.
SPEAKER 5: You're
at the fourth I/O?
SPEAKER 4: Yeah.
SPEAKER 5: First one for me.
SPEAKER 6: First one for me too.
SPEAKER 7: I have
probably seven festivals.
MEGHAN MEHTA: Seven!
Oh my gosh.
You're a veteran.
SPEAKER 7: Yeah.
MEGHAN MEHTA: What was your
favorite technology that Google
came out with this year?
SPEAKER 8: Flutter!
Flutter!
SPEAKER 1: Assistant.
Everything about the Assistant.
The upgrades are fantastic.
MEGHAN MEHTA: What's
your guys' favorite thing
that you've seen so far?
SPEAKER 3: Definitely the--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SPEAKER 3: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER 9: What was the name
of the people that were dancing
on the ice cream van here?
MEGHAN MEHTA: The fungineers?
SPEAKER 9: They were amazing.
They were so funny.
SPEAKER 2: I think the live
captions seem really, really
cool.
MEGHAN MEHTA: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: I don't know.
I just feel like it's gonna
change a lot of people's lives.
SPEAKER 7: Anything with
Google Photos as well.
SPEAKER 4: For me it's the
environments or the people--
or the people just working
in something creative
with technology.
And I think that's amazing.
MEGHAN MEHTA: What is the
craziest thing you've ever
asked your Google Assistant?
SPEAKER 1: Am I hungry?
SPEAKER 7: Will I
ever find a husband?
MEGHAN MEHTA: I'm
just saying, there's
a ton of men around here.
SPEAKER 7: It's true.
SPEAKER 10: I have a
five-year-old niece.
And she loves
having conversations
with the Google Assistant.
She's like, what's
your favorite color?
And do you want to go
to the moon with me?
MEGHAN MEHTA: Next I/O, if
Google could do anything,
what would you want
to see next year?
SPEAKER 1: Smell o vision.
MEGHAN MEHTA: I love it!
I want smell o vision!
SPEAKER 1: So we can see
it and we can hear it.
Let's be able to smell it now.
SPEAKER 9: How about
a car that hovers?
MEGHAN MEHTA: I love it.
SPEAKER 10: Well, it
drives itself as well.
SPEAKER 9: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]
at the same time.
SPEAKER 10:
Self-driving hover car.
SPEAKER 11: I would like to see
more integration towards humans
and artificial intelligence.
So it's not about artificial
intelligence only,
but I think the future that
Google is trying to build
or should build is a combination
of artificial intelligence
with humans.
SPEAKER 12: Google Barber.
MEGHAN MEHTA: Google Barber?
What is that?
SPEAKER 12: So
think of it, right?
Each time I go to the salon,
I want people to know exactly
would haircut I want.
So based on my activities and my
actions and my previous haircut
history, it could basically
tell me what exactly I want.
SPEAKER 13: If they could
do the Google Assistant
in [INAUDIBLE],,
our local language,
if they could support
Google in [INAUDIBLE],,
that would be awesome.
MEGHAN MEHTA: Oh, great.
What do you want
to see next year?
SPEAKER 14: AR dog
watching, fox to trot?
MEGHAN MEHTA: AR dog walking.
You heard it here first.
It's our next trend.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Welcome back,
and thanks for hanging out
with us on I/O Live.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
EMILY FORTUNA: And
I'm Emily Fortuna.
Our next guest is a real
pioneer, an engineer,
physician, and NASA
astronaut, Dr. Mae C. Jemison.
What an honor to have you here.
MAE C. JEMISON:
Thank you very much.
It's exciting to be
here today as well.
It's a beautiful, sunny day,
EMILY FORTUNA:
Definitely, very bright.
You've had an extremely
impressive career spanning
so many different fields.
What do you see as
the through lines
throughout all of
these different fields?
MAE C. JEMISON: So when
I think about the things
that I've done from having
been a chemical engineer
and a medical doctor, and then
an astronaut, and then as soon
as I left NASA, I started an
international science camp
called the Earth We Share
as an environmental studies
professor, 100 Year Starship.
Throughout them is the
idea that we're connected.
And how do we use our
technological prowess,
our resources to help
better the world writ large?
And I know that sounds
kind of Pollyanna-ish,
but my revelation
as I've grown up,
as I've looked around the world,
as I've lived different places,
it's that this planet
has incredible resources,
but they're finite.
The resources include people
and their talents that
exist everywhere in the world.
It includes our plant
life, our animal life,
not just the things you can
dig up out of the ground.
And we have to protect
those, and we also
have to understand
that we share them.
And if I go a
little bit further,
it's like pushing the envelope.
Not being satisfied
with this is complacent.
I always have to
challenge myself.
And perhaps I push
and grab on things
that are really
different or difficult,
but for me the energy
comes with trying something
that I don't know that I can
absolutely accomplish it.
That it's going to require
something new for me.
That it's going to
require me to grow.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: During
your presentation here,
you spoke about your 100
Year Starship initiative.
And to introduce
it, and I love this,
you spoke about how
Mars is too close.
Why is that, and why should
we set our sights further out?
MAE C. JEMISON: So I'm going to
be perfectly honest with you.
When I was growing up, I
assumed that by the time
I became an astronaut--
I actually didn't even
want to be an astronaut.
I just assumed
I'd go into space.
But that I'd be
going to Mars or one
of the moons around Jupiter,
or Saturn or something.
That's what I thought because
we had all these things that
were happening.
In fact, we had probes on
Mars when I was a little kid.
So of course, we'll be
doing something more.
The reason I talk about
100 Years Starship
from the perspective
of it's more audacious
than Mars is because Mars
doesn't push us hard enough.
We've been on Mars
multiple times.
We've got Mars'
addressed, right?
We can figure out the
technological timeline
to do Mars, the technologies
that are needed.
The reason we
haven't gone to Mars
is not so much an
engineering challenge,
it's a public commitment.
But what's going
to really push us
is thinking about
interstellar, which
also captures our imagination.
That doesn't mean
that we don't do Mars.
It means, let's do something
that's big and audacious
and keep that in our eye sight.
So 100 Year Starship
was seed funded by DARPA
to make sure we have
the capabilities
for human interstellar flight.
But the real underlying
current there is innovation.
How do we get the radical
leaps in knowledge,
in technologies,
in human systems
that would allow us to go
to another star system?
Now, that's the real piece.
Because each one of those
challenges that we meet
can be applied to life
here on earth right today.
You can't go to
another star system
with humans using the
kind of energy systems
we have today for
space exploration.
You know, the chemical rockets
and propulsion and stuff.
We're going to have to generate
tremendous amounts of energy
through either a
fission where you break
an atom apart, a fusion,
like what powers the sun,
or antimatter.
We do fission now, but
it's not well contained.
We don't know how to
control it, store it.
Imagine if we could just
learn how to store this.
What tremendous value would it
have for life here on earth?
When you think about going
to another star system,
you have to be autonomous.
So you have to carry
your food with you.
Because if you get to going fast
enough-- it's a hard journey.
But if you get to going
fast enough so it's
reasonable within
human lifetimes,
you're going to have to
carry everything with you.
You're going to
have to learn how
to grow your food,
your medical systems.
And right now when
we're on earth,
we rely on this wonderful
biodiversity of the soil,
the microbiome in the soil,
and all of those things
to grow food.
We need to understand that.
We need to know how
to keep it healthy.
We need to take that with us.
And so there are
all these pieces,
financial
infrastructures, we have
to change to be
able to do something
that's that long term.
And if you stop and
think about that,
those are all things we need
to survive on this planet.
EMILY FORTUNA: Space
exploration seems
inevitable with the requisite
what you call team earthlings.
But at the same time, it seems
like we could be moving faster.
What do you think
is holding us back?
MAE C. JEMISON: I think
it's public commitment.
It's really, we haven't
included people.
And so folks don't see how space
technology impacts their day
to day lives even
though it does.
I live in Houston, Texas.
We track hurricanes.
And that's what we know about.
We knew about the
hole in the ozone
from space information and data.
So it's constantly
pervasive in our lives,
but we haven't told
the story very well.
And when I say we, that's
I guess the royal we
about space folks.
And you tell the story better
by having people involved.
What was riveting
people when Mars landed?
You know, the Mars
Lander, remember everybody
was looking and cheering?
It's because they could see
it, they could be a part of it.
And I think that's the piece.
And I think that's the
piece with all science
and technology.
When it's accessible and
when people understand
that it's part of their
lives and it's not
this mysterious thing.
EMILY FORTUNA: And they're
energized and excited
towards working
towards that goal.
MAE C. JEMISON: And I
think one of the things
that space offices and also
other technology innovations
offer us is that we get
to do bigger things,
and I think people would like--
they like an adrenaline rush.
But wouldn't we like to do good
things with adrenaline rush?
Right now, we
manufacture adrenaline
rushes in ways that are not
necessarily so productive,
there you go.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Sure.
How does this
relate to your theme
of Look Up and the Skyfie
app that you produced?
MAE C. JEMISON: So Look Up
came from 100 Year Starship,
and we wanted to connect
people with space,
and we also wanted to deal with
the issue of human behavior.
How do we get the
best out of us?
And we thought, let's ask
people to go out and look up.
Like when was the last
time you looked up?
Remember as a kid
looking up at the clouds?
And it just made you
feel good, right?
And then I remember
as a child thinking
that there are other children
on the other side of the planet
who are looking up as well.
And what do they see?
I know they see the same moon.
In some instances, they see
slightly different stars.
But it was just one of
those connecting things.
And so we started
to work on how do we
create a campaign where
one day around the world,
we'd all look up?
And so of course, we had to
make an app for that, right?
And that's where the
Skyfie app came in.
So sky, selfie.
And the idea is to take
an image, a video, a text,
or whatever when you look up.
What does it make you feel?
Post it, and we would
put it on a globe
that you can twirl
around and you can see
what everyone else is doing.
And it's time tagged and
data tagged to where you are,
and you get to see what
other people are looking at.
What we came up with is that
we want to do different events.
So we started on
October 18, one day.
I'm proud to say we trended
number five on Google
Play, which is great.
But in one day, we were able
to garner lots of enthusiasm
and support around the world.
Of course, it took a lot of
work to build up to that.
And now we're continuing
to work on it,
and we're going to do one also
around the 50th anniversary
of the Lunar landing.
I'd like everybody
to-- can I do this?
The Skyfie app is
completely free.
No in-app purchases.
I know that's like,
what is wrong with her?
No, it's because we want
people to connect and use it.
And it's available on Google,
it's available on IOS systems.
And the idea is to
really just connect us.
And I think as we were
talking before, just
the act of looking up from your
phone changes your perspective.
You get bigger, you look out.
Just the act of looking up
from your desk or your work,
or just sometimes I'm
walking down the street,
I'm looking at the ground.
Looking up, it frees us.
It gives us energy.
EMILY FORTUNA: So I
have one more question--
and this is on behalf--
MAE C. JEMISON:
Wait, wait, wait.
You're going to blame Timothy?
EMILY FORTUNA: Timothy asked
me to ask this question.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Between the two of us,
the biggest Star Trek
nerd is probably me.
MAE C. JEMISON: OK, shoot.
EMILY FORTUNA: So I know
that Nichelle Nichols
is a huge inspiration to you.
And I personally believe
that representation in media
is super important.
And I wanted to ask
how you got your guest
appearance on Star Trek?
MAE C. JEMISON: So
let me just start off
by saying, when I was growing
up, I loved Star Trek.
I was in Los Angeles before I
was accepted into the astronaut
program, and I used to
get my hair cut in LA.
And the person who cut
my hair was [INAUDIBLE]
who was a hair dresser
in all these movies
and things like that.
And he knew LeVar Burton.
And [? Sterphon ?] and
I were talking one day,
and he said, Mae, would you
like to be on-- why don't you
be on Star Trek?
And I said, really?
So he said, I'll
mention it to LeVar.
So he mentioned it to LeVar.
So I got a call one night.
I was at home, and it's like,
hey, Mae, this is LeVar Burton.
Would you be interested
in being on Star Trek?
That's what [? Sterphon ?] said.
And I was like, yeah, sure.
Like, this is when
the glasses come off.
Yes, sure.
And they wrote a part for
me as Lieutenant Palmer.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
MAE C. JEMISON: And that's
what happened, basically.
It was an episode
LeVar was directing,
and it was really very neat.
And I was able to go around have
been sort of one of the Star
Trek buddies since then, and
was even able to help them
when they premiered the
Star Trek Discovery back
last year in New York.
EMILY FORTUNA: That's wonderful.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really cool.
All right, before we
go, is there anything
else you'd like to
tell our viewers?
MAE C. JEMISON: Well, all this
discussion we're having now
is really around science and
technology and some of those
issues.
And it's really important
that we understand
that we research science
and problems based
on the people who are there.
Their ambitions, their dreams,
their goals, their fears.
And so it's really
important that we
have as many people as
possible doing that work.
We design technology and tools
based on the people we are.
It's important that we have
lots of people involved.
And we fail to develop and
use so much of the talent
in this country.
So I spend a lot of my time
around science literacy,
and I think it's
vitally important
that every child
have an opportunity
for an excellent education,
that every child is
science literate.
As adults, that we
don't sort of say, oh,
I don't know about that.
You know, that's not cute.
We need to make sure
that we're fully engaged,
and that's my task, to
be inclusive and bring
lots of people along.
EMILY FORTUNA: Here, here.
Dr. Jemison, thank you
so much for joining us
on this show today.
MAE C. JEMISON:
You're very welcome.
Thank you.
I get to shake hands.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you.
EMILY FORTUNA: And
what could be more
appropriate to follow this talk
than a demo with its own Mars
Rover?
Take it away, Todd.
TODD KERPELMAN:
Hello I/O viewers.
I am here with Amanda in
the augmented reality booth,
and Amanda, you're going to show
me something cool from the NASA
website.
AMANDA LE: So, here you can
see on the NASA website,
they're showing 3D
models of their rovers.
Here, we have the
Curiosity Rover.
And they're actually using
the Model VR web component
to put that 3D asset
on their website.
TODD KERPELMAN: Wow,
that's very cool.
Now, you said it's
a web component, so
do they need to NPM install
something to get it working?
AMANDA LE: It's
actually mark up.
So very simple to just
put on your website.
TODD KERPELMAN: Got you.
Well, that's very cool.
And this 3D model, what
file format is that?
AMANDA LE: So we
recommend using GLTF,
but it also supports
USDZ and GLB.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
And is that something most
commercial 3D modeling
tools will export to?
AMANDA LE: You should be able
to export to that easily.
TODD KERPELMAN: I see you've got
that little button down there
in the bottom right.
What does that do?
AMANDA LE: So this
actually is the new feature
that we're launching
at I/O today.
And what it allows you
to do is open up what
we call Scene Viewer.
So Scene Viewer allows you
to take these 3D models
and actually place it in
your real world space.
TODD KERPELMAN: Woah, no way.
AMANDA LE: So here you can see
the Curiosity Rover at scale.
TODD KERPELMAN: Wow,
it's like there's
a real life spaceship here
in the booth, but not really.
It's just actually
very nicely rendered.
It kind of fooled me.
AMANDA LE: Yup, and so you
can actually manipulate
this in your own space.
So you'll see it at full
scale, but you can also
shrink it down so
that it can actually
fit in your living room.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK, yes.
So if I want to put the
Curiosity Rover on my coffee
table, I now can just by
shrinking it down a little bit.
AMANDA LE: Yup.
TODD KERPELMAN: And so how did
you get the size specification?
Like apparently this
was built real life,
or this is showing
it in real life
and you're able
to shrink it down?
AMANDA LE: Yeah, so NASA
when they built the 3D model,
they decided to
build it at scale.
So that's the model
we're referencing.
TODD KERPELMAN: Got you.
Very cool.
And so if I'm a developer and
I want to turn my model viewer
component into this
cool scene viewer
augmented reality experience,
what do I have to do?
AMANDA LE: So there's no need
to build an app for this.
All you actually do is
go into the mark-up,
and you add the AR
attribute, which
is literally the letters a
and r, so super simple to do.
TODD KERPELMAN: I type two
letters and I get all that.
AMANDA LE: Yes.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right,
well that sounds easy.
I think even I could do that.
Well, I could use a little
pick me up after that demo.
Let's head out over here and
see if I can find some caffeine.
Hey, Ashish.
ASHISH SHAH: How
are you doing, Todd?
TODD KERPELMAN: I am doing well.
I'm already excited
for this demo,
because I see there's an
Espresso machine here.
So walk me through what
you're showing us today.
ASHISH SHAH: All right,
so what are doing in here
is we're showing an espresso
machine coming to life in AR
using this technology called
augmented images that's
part of AR Core.
Do you want to give it a spin?
TODD KERPELMAN: Yes,
let's check it out.
ASHISH SHAH: All
right, so as soon
as you look at this marker--
TODD KERPELMAN: So you're
showing the image there,
and it's telling
you to look around.
ASHISH SHAH: And now it's
annotated the machine
with information
about its features.
TODD KERPELMAN: I see the
little pieces coming to life.
ASHISH SHAH: Yep,
it's telling you
about those control grinding--
TODD KERPELMAN: I need
my doses controlled.
ASHISH SHAH: And the
precise temperature.
What would you do without that?
And you could actually see
an espresso being made here.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh, fantastic.
ASHISH SHAH: This is a really
powerful way for manufacturers
to show features
of their product
which are otherwise
just lost in text,
and this really makes
the product come to life
in a really powerful way.
And so this triggers the
experience once it recognizes.
And now what happens once
this image is recognized,
it starts establishing
a correspondence
between the phone and the image.
TODD KERPELMAN: So
the phone always knows
exactly where it is in
response to this image.
ASHISH SHAH: With
respect to the image.
And when I say it establishes
a correspondence in terms
of oppose, that's
position and orientation.
So position in x
direction and y direction
and in z direction, and also
the orientation in three degrees
like pitch, yaw, and roll.
So the phone knows
exactly where it
is with respect to the marker.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
So this kind of
works best in places
where you have strict
control over the environment
in which this image is going
to appear and what's around it.
ASHISH SHAH: Yes.
If you're trying to
augment real things,
you want to make sure
that the image is
rigid with respect to the thing
that you're trying to augment.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
But if you just want the image
itself specifically to come
to life, that's all you need.
ASHISH SHAH: Absolutely.
So think about a scenario
where you're at a store,
and you want to see
what's inside a box.
So you could use an
app to look at the box.
It would recognize
the box as a marker,
and you could actually
have a sneak peek
at what's inside the box.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh, so the
model could pop out of the box,
and you could see exactly what
my waffle iron or toaster--
I need stuff for my kitchen--
that's all going to look like.
ASHISH SHAH: Without
even opening it up.
TODD KERPELMAN: And then I won't
get yelled at by shopkeepers.
Well, thank you
very much, Ashish.
I learned a lot about
augmented reality today.
I'm going to grab
this espresso--
oh, it's not real.
But the coffee beans are.
Can I eat the coffee beans?
ASHISH SHAH: Yes, you can.
TODD KERPELMAN: I'm going to
take a few coffee beans to go.
Thank you very much live stream.
I'm going to go get caffeinated.
EMILY FORTUNA: AR really spans
the outer limits, up to Mars
and back down to a
simple cup of coffee.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well,
one fancy cup of coffee.
And you have a minute
to grab one yourself
while we take a quick break.
The next sessions
are about to begin.
You're watching I/O live from
Mountain View, California.
Welcome back to I/O Live.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and we're honored
to have renowned artist
Sougwen Chung here
to talk about her work.
Welcome.
SOUGWEN CHUNG: Hi.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Now,
I've been looking forward
to your performance here at I/O,
and I'd like to talk about it.
But first, how about
some background?
When did you start working
with robots and why?
SOUGWEN CHUNG: It's
a great question.
I get asked that all the time
I started working with robots
about five years ago.
I've been kind of
a digital nomad.
I learned to code when
I was quite young,
and I got really
interested in ways
to take what's present inside
the simulation of the computer
into the physical world.
So I started with a really
simple drawing collaboration
with my first robotic arm, and
it's just taken off ever since.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: How has
the experience of, say,
human machine
collaboration changed
your process as an artist?
SOUGWEN CHUNG: I think
about that a lot,
because I think it has changed
it quite significantly.
I've gotten more accustomed
to chaos, to put it mildly.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Things going
not the way you expected?
SOUGWEN CHUNG: Yeah, there's
a lot of erratic emergent
behavior or assigned
attributed behavior
to working with these machines
that really got me out
of outside of my comfort zone
from just my simple drawing
practice.
I think there's something really
[INAUDIBLE] and the cognitive
about mark making that when
you do that with a robotic
articulated unit, it--
there's a lot of new surprises.
I like to think of working
with these machines
as a creative catalyst,
so that ends up
being quite inspiring for me.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Interesting.
All right, let's talk about
the performance a little bit.
It was beautiful and elegant.
SOUGWEN CHUNG: Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I
expected that part,
because I looked at
your work online.
What I didn't expect was
something completely different,
that your relationship
with the robots
felt if I can say gentle
and familial, like they
were a family.
SOUGWEN CHUNG: Yeah, yeah.
They pretty much
are at this point.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I mean,
tell me about that.
How much of what you're
doing about the art
is about that relationship
rather than the marks
that you're making?
SOUGWEN CHUNG: Yeah, definitely.
So I implicate the tool as a
collaborator, and I think--
I frame it as a
collaboration, because we
want to facilitate kind,
generous collaborations
in the world between
humans to humans.
And I think when I regard these
machines as my collaborators,
it's a way of just creating
a more empathetic model.
In this context, it's
behavioral empathy.
But when I'm on stage
performing with these robots,
I think it's very much me and
them and this captive audience,
and that mutual reliance
and co-creation ends up
spreading a very emotional
connection with them.
And I think that we've evolved.
Like my process has
evolved significantly
with this collaborative
work, and they have as well.
I think it's a positive way
of slanting anthromorphism
that's just been really
inspiring for the work.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Did
you have to do anything
to build that relationship
like hang out with him outside
of work?
SOUGWEN CHUNG: Yeah, we get
a few beers every so often.
Yeah, no.
It's honestly, there's so much
vitality and vulnerability
when doing these
performances that we've
kind of been in this together
with the risk of sounding a bit
cheesy.
Has made it feel like a
really close connection.
In addition to the
robotic arms, I've
been designing a multi
robotic system that's actually
a series of 20
painting robots that
also is an articulation
of this robotic form
in a different way.
Instead of one to
one, it's one to many.
And that is a totally
different relationship.
It's almost like a natural swarm
that I'm really excited about.
So that reframes the
relationship too.
Yeah, it's embodied
kinetic sculpture.
That's only possible
in today's moments,
and that really excites me.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
It's really cool.
SOUGWEN CHUNG: Thanks.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK,
the themes of the work
that you performed here--
mimicry, memory, and
future speculations.
How did you land on this?
SOUGWEN CHUNG: So the mimicry
was the first generation.
I call my robots Doug,
because the project is named--
let's just drop the formalities
and call them what they are.
No, I started the
project, and it's
called Drawing Operations Unit
Generation One was focused
on mimicry, and
that was DOUG One,
and it's sort of
grown over time.
It's a mimicry, memory,
and future speculations,
because those are the three
chapters of this evolving
generational project.
So I'm really excited
about the third,
because it shows multi
robotic collaboration
alongside my human
drawing agency.
And that's very
much where the work
is headed, towards a
more collaborative, more
collective idea.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Is there
a fourth generation
you have in mind?
SOUGWEN CHUNG: Yeah, there is.
Well, the third
generation is actually
the multi robotic system,
which is the painting ones.
But there's a fourth generation
that I can't talk about yet,
but it'll be coming soon.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome,
well I'll look forward to it.
SOUGWEN CHUNG: I'm
excited to share.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: The score
for the work by Aquariun,
how did that contribute
to your work?
SOUGWEN CHUNG: It
contributed so much.
Acquariun has been a good
friend of mine for quite a while
and does some
incredible music that
is actually quite brilliant.
Like, I think I
was describing it
earlier as it's
futuristic but also taps
into this nostalgia about
jungle and drum and bass
that's really,
really interesting.
I sort of asked him to come
up with the score for me
and discussed with
him about the themes
I'd like him to interpret.
So he really came up with
a beautiful melodic work
that really adds so
much to the piece.
We were really excited to
collaborate with and use the 40
Sound System from Monome
and spatialize this work.
One component of the
performance that we did,
especially for I/O,
was the integration
of a Contact Mic component.
So in the beginning,
my drawing gestures
actually form architectural
sound throughout the space.
And it was really cool
to control the universe
of the performance like that.
So we were very excited about
it and hope to do again soon.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
One more question.
I have to ask this.
What's the biggest surprise
your sort of robot partner
has ever given you
in a performance?
SOUGWEN CHUNG: I like
your verbiage with that.
It's a very-- because I do
think about it as like giving
of the artistic behavior.
I think it's been
incredibly surprising.
I think one of the reasons I've
been working with neural nets
is its ability to and its
native ability to generate
non-human unexpected behaviors.
It's been a really interesting
way of looking at my own work,
because I train all my neural
nets on my own drawings
to kind of re-examine
the type of work I do
and see how it feels to
be articulated by a unit.
So I think it's
constantly surprising
me, which is probably not the
answer you're looking for.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I don't know,
I think that's a great answer.
SOUGWEN CHUNG: I
will say what I do
find surprising about the duets
is not only the robot's output,
but the response to it has
been really interesting.
And it's really taken off a
lot of speculative questions
about technology and
philosophy and sort
of what it means to make
work as an artist today.
So that's been the most
surprising connection
that this performance
has created for me.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Thank you for that.
And thanks for sharing
your vision and your art
with us here at I/O 19.
SOUGWEN CHUNG: Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Next up, let's join
Wayne for more in the sandbox.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Hi,
I'm Wayne Piekarski,
and welcome to Google I/O 2019.
We're here at
Shoreline Amphitheatre,
where there's a bunch of really
cool demos and exhibits and fun
things to do.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to take you on a live guided
tour of all the really
cool stuff here.
So let's go and get started.
Oh wow, look.
You can see all of these
augmented reality flowers.
Wow, look.
I got augmented reality
glasses and hair.
So we've got Flutter running
on iOS and Android devices
and tablets and everything.
It looks great.
And I got a free snack.
OK, let's try this one here.
What's the temperature outside?
A perfect day.
Exactly.
It's always like that at
I/O. All right, let's go.
I guess I should see what the
latest news is from my bosses
here.
So it's really cool, because you
can use either a remote control
or a game controller, and
you can control your TV
to play games, watch YouTube
videos, see what's going on.
Experiments with Google.
So what we're
doing here is we've
got a machine learning
algorithm that's been
trained with animal sounds.
And the more accurately
you can make them,
the faster your little tractor
drives around the track here.
This is so much fun.
How was your experiment?
Awesome.
All right, so here,
we're in the gaming area,
where we're seeing lots of
demos, interesting things.
These are all
targeted at developers
who actually make games for
Android and web and so forth.
So there's a lot of really
interesting news and updates
for them.
But what we should
do now is let's
go and check out what Stadia
has to offer for a demo.
Let's check it out.
So here we have
Stadia, which allows
us to play games on the Cloud.
So what do we have here?
SPEAKER 15: This is a developer
tool demo that we have.
So what you see here is
we've taken this 2D image,
and we've trained a machine
learning model offline,
and we can apply it directly
in the game at runtime.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Let's
take a walk around.
Can I play it?
So this is using shaders, or--
SPEAKER 15: It's using
machine learning technology
with shaders.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Wow,
this is really cool.
Thanks very much.
All right, let's get out of
here and see what else there is.
You are talking to this.
Oh, come on.
Oh, I got something.
This thing is insanely accurate.
All right, you can check
out my poses on the screen.
Oh, look at this.
What a superstar.
OK, so is the Android
auto area, where we have
Android that runs in vehicles.
So what we see here is
that we've got actually
a head unit from a
vehicle mounted here,
and then the phone is
projecting onto the screen.
And so the phone can allow
us to run Google Maps,
make phone calls,
play music, whatever.
It's really neat, because you
can do all the same functions
from your phone,
but you can do it
in a nice head mounted
in your vehicle.
Let's go see if we can get
a sneak peek inside one
of the cars themselves.
Come on, let's go.
All right, here we have
and Android AutoCast.
This is exciting.
So we've got Google
Maps, we've our phone,
we can make calls with
it, listen to our music.
So let's get ready
to take a drive.
So the Android Auto people
wouldn't let me take their car,
so instead I thought I'd
come over here and try out
this virtual moped
ride, where I get
to ride through the
streets of Jakarta
watching a 360 video on these
virtual reality glasses here.
What's really cool is
you can do a 360 video.
When you're sitting
in a motorcycle,
it feels so
incredibly realistic.
All right, well that was
an amazing whirlwind tour
of Jakarta on a 360
degree YouTube video.
And this is also a great
tour of the Sandboxes
at Google I/O 2019.
I hope you had as
much fun as I did
watching everything
that's going on here,
and I'll see you next time.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: The Sandbox
is such a great place
to really become
immersed in everything
featured at I/O this year.
And if you missed any part
of I/O live, you're in luck.
You can check it all
out at g.co/io/live.
We'll see you after
these sessions.
NARRATOR: Learn to
architect and develop
Android apps in the Kotlin
programming language
using industry proven
tools and libraries.
Creating Android apps in Kotlin
is a course developed by Google
together with Udacity.
You'll learn by building real
Android apps using industry
best practices with
modern app architecture.
Understand why and how to use
Andrew Jetpack components,
such as room for
databases, Work Manager
for background processing,
the new navigation
components, and more.
You'll use key Kotlin features
to write your app code
more quickly and concisely.
Learning to develop
on Android is
much more than learning
APIs and shortcuts.
It's training your brain to
think like a mobile developer.
Come learn with us.
For more information on this
free course and to see all
of Google's courses
with Udacity,
go to udacity.com/google.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
One of the things
I love about I/O is
the intersection of art
and technology, which is why
we're able to speak with people
like Amit, the director of
Google's Arts and Culture,
and Google Distinguished
Scientist, Blaise.
Welcome both to the show.
AMIT SOOD: Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
How are you doing?
AMIT SOOD: Very well.
You?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm doing
really, really great.
So Amit, let's start with some
background on Google's Cultural
Institute and Google's
arts and cultures.
How did it get started,
and what's the mission?
AMIT SOOD: Sure.
I think most of it is
publicly available.
But I think the
short version is it
was a grounds up 20% initiative
by a couple of Googlers
back in 2010, 2011,
to essentially do
one very simple thing.
To make access to art and
culture truly accessible
online without any
barriers to entry
by working with museums,
artists, and institutions.
And since then, the
initiative is now formalized.
It's a non-profit
within the company,
and essentially it focuses
on telling stories,
on getting cultural
content onto the internet,
and essentially collaborating
with amazing artists
and great engineers.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: One of the
first things that I heard about
was the Museum of Museums, I
think it was called one point.
Being able to go online
and see these works of art
in such high detail.
Like you could even
see the brush strokes.
And that was an
incredible start.
What are some of
the other things?
AMIT SOOD: Well, I
think we are very lucky.
When you start a project like
this and you work at Google,
you get access to teams.
Like for example, Blaise's
team, or for example Geo Team,
that goes and builds
cameras for you
that allows you to
essentially take
Street View inside a museum or
to take high resolution giga
pixel images.
So these were the kind
of starting points
for the experience.
And now we have moved into
things like art selfies,
so making sure that
people have a deeper
appreciation for
portraits that are
lying in museums
around the world
by matching them to a selfie.
And this was one of our
features that crossed
over 100 million
selfies have been
taken, where people
are now finding
a new way to interact with art.
MEGHAN MEHTA: And
that's the one that's
using style transfer, an
aspect of machine learning.
AMIT SOOD: It is using an
aspect of machine learning, yes.
And it's done on device, and
it's really one of those things
that we didn't
expect to take off
in the way it did, and
neither did the museums.
Because they've been just
preserving these artworks
without understanding
that there can
be a new relationship
with the audience
that's not one of education,
but one of interaction.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really cool.
All right, let's talk about
art and machine intelligence
in a little bit more depth.
I think you've called
it an emerging practice.
What are we seeing, and where?
Who's doing what?
BLAISE AGUERA Y
ARCAS: Well, there's
actually sort of a
natural flow from what
Google Arts and Culture
started to do many years ago.
And where we began with the
artist and machine intelligence
program in 2015.
The first thing that became
possible with deep learning
was the analysis of these
artworks and of visual media
in general, in which
you start to be
able to extract the
semantics of those things
and go beyond exploration,
beyond Street View type things
and into search and
semantic analysis.
But then, what really sort
of flipped a bit in our minds
was Alex Mordvintsev's
Deep Dream work.
You remember the trippy
squirrel and all that stuff.
MEGHAN MEHTA: It's creepy and
beautiful all at the same time.
BLAISE AGUERA Y ARCAS:
Creepy and wonderful
and leaked just
shortly before we--
it somewhat accelerated
our need to get out there
with what this actually was.
But that was the first
time that neural nets
began to sort of invert.
And there's been a
long running thread
in machine learning of
doing synthesis and not
just analysis.
But in the era of
classical machine learning,
that wasn't generally
very successful,
because the actual
machine learning
part of machine learning
prior to deep learning
was very low dimensional.
So everything relied
on feature engineering.
You write lots of code to
reduce whatever media you're
talking about to a
handful of dimensions,
and then you end up
doing regression.
And so inverting through
feature engineering is hard.
You can do maybe generated
faces in a video game
with different
proportions or something,
but you're not going
to generate things
that are all that realistic
or artistically interesting.
But with Deep Dream,
the realization
was that since neural
nets work with very, very
high dimensional inputs directly
and don't rely on feature
engineering, you can turn that
engine around the other way,
and suddenly you
have the machinery
for not only understanding
but also synthesizing media.
And that raises all of these
very profound questions.
So it's not just
new art practices
that emerge from that, but
new philosophical questions
about the relationship
of creativity
and human exceptionalism
to computing.
And so that's where
those additional layers
of cultural
engagement came from.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Or even the
relatively simple question of
are we seeing the output
of Deep Dream, is that
the mind of that neural network?
BLAISE AGUERA Y
ARCAS: Yeah, yeah.
And in fact, in the
beginning, the reason
that Alex did that
experiment was
to do a kind of neuroscience
on those networks.
Originally it was
visualization of what
those neurons high up in
that neural net were actually
sensitive to.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's crazy.
All right, so at I/O, you all
have announced the Artists
and Machine Intelligence
Grants, so what's the goal
and who's eligible?
AMIT SOOD: I can give
a very quick thing
and then let Blaise
explain more.
But I think for us, partnering
with Blaise's team is natural,
because they're essentially
at the forefront of what's
happening in machine
learning, and we
are trying to get
museums and artists
to adopt those technologies by
creating beautiful prototypes
or experiments.
So we've launched a program
called Google Arts and Culture
Experiments, and over there,
you get all different types
of artists, studios,
and individuals
who are partnering either
with an institution
or with a technologist to
create a new experiment.
And we were trying to figure
out how can we further that
and how can we maybe
structure that in a way that
is a bit more appealing?
And that's where
Blaise's team came
in with the idea of the grants.
BLAISE AGUERA Y ARCAS: And
Google Arts and Culture
has always been interested
in not only engaging
with institutions
but moving upstream
with artists, of course.
So it was a very obvious
synergy from the beginning.
But beyond just tool
making or building
bridges between artists
and technologists,
a number of those
grants are actually
being given to philosophers
and theorists, people
who cross over, who are
very multidisciplinary,
not only between
arts and technology
but also thinking, critical
theory, media analysis,
philosophy, aesthetics.
Because it's again,
it's not just
a sort of trick for
synthesizing trippy images.
It also is a tool, and a--
AMIT SOOD: It's a deeper
question about where this goes.
BLAISE AGUERA Y
ARCAS: Yeah, it's
a tool for thinking
about very deep questions
about what humans are all
about, what creativity
is all about, what is the future
relationship between humans
and machines and
society and so on.
AMIT SOOD: So we have
very meta topics,
and then we need
to find ways that
can be easily explainable or
communicated to the audience.
And that's where I think the
synergy of this program is--
for us, it's our first attempt.
It's the first time
we have announced
this program together.
So we are hoping the
output will be interesting,
and then hopefully we can
scale it and expand it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
it's so important
to involve artists in
those kinds of questions.
AMIT SOOD: Exactly, exactly.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
let's fast forward.
I understand the program
runs from September
to January of 2020.
In February of 2020, how
does the world look different
if this goes perfectly well?
BLAISE AGUERA Y ARCAS:
Well, obviously there
are works that we hope will come
out of this whole process that
will be beautiful or frightening
or engage discussion, or--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Or
all of those things.
BLAISE AGUERA Y
ARCAS: In various ways
all of the above, perhaps.
So certainly, there
are artistic outputs
that we expect will happen.
But a big part of this is
also about advancing dialogue,
and it's not a marketing
exercise for Google.
We have felt from the beginning
that the two-way dialogue,
the influence of a
lot of those thinkers
on what we're doing
in our other work
is at least as important
from our point of view
as just making tools
available to the artists.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank
you for being here,
and if they want to
check this out online,
there's a URL right?
AMIT SOOD: Yeah,
they've just got to go
to go.co/ArtsExperiments.
And they can apply for
the grants program,
they can learn more
about RMI's work,
and it's a fascinating
place to be.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Gentlemen,
thank you so much for joining me
on the show today.
AMIT SOOD: Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We're going
to take a quick break now,
and then we'll be back
with more I/O Live.
EMILY FORTUNA: It has been
a jam packed I/O this year,
and I'm sorry it's already over.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Right?
I mean, we've covered so much.
It's been an amazing three days.
EMILY FORTUNA: Thank you all for
tuning in and experiencing it
with us.
Though we're
wrapping up this I/O,
keep the conversation
going with hashtag I/O 19.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And to
watch all the keynotes,
all of the sessions, and
all the I/O Live content,
visit g.co/io/live, or
head directly to the Google
Developers YouTube channel.
EMILY FORTUNA: And to
stay connected with Google
Developers, sign up
for our newsletter,
at g.co/dev/newsletter.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
long from I/O 2019.
EMILY FORTUNA: See you in 2020.
SYNTHESIZED VOICE: Good
morning, Shore Line.
Welcome to Google I/O.
SUNDAR PICHAI: Thank you
all for joining us in person
and to the millions around the
world watching on Livestream.
TODD KERPELMAN:
Right, experiments.
Let's go check it out.
SPEAKER 16: Today, there are
over 2.5 billion active Android
devices.
SPEAKER 17: The vibe's great,
the people here are amazing.
SPEAKER 18: The sessions,
the food, the people--
everything is perfect.
SPEAKER 19: 10 years.
10 years of our Google
developer community.
Each of you do so much to help.
We appreciate everything
you do for us.
SPEAKER 20: Here is our friend.
SPEAKER 21: It's an AR shark.
It won't bite.
SPEAKER 22: Oh, that's so nifty.
SPEAKER 23: It's
a perfect example
of what we mean
by building a more
helpful Google for everyone.
[MUSIC PLAYING]